yes hello and welcome to this video
playing I am Tobin Toby something like
that so mmm what do we get I wonder
about that flag more time see yes I
don't think that h5 is objectively great
day I've tried that a couple of tackles
but it didn't didn't work out all that
great so I just do normal moose okay so
it's not G for something here I think
after prepare b6 that we have done that
immediately that would be b5 and some
nice move problem so let's get out of
them
yeah is opening up the B file but it
looks like still a decent structure for
black ok so b6 here you can even think
about an a5 night before basehead this
this needs preparation should not
blunder age 6
yeah well a five night before is not
something that particularly excites me
[Music]
total an interesting so I cannot take
twice
I do mind so much if he takes enough to
take with the e pawn what would think
this is so so bad
sits and this is an annoying piece here
for sure maybe this one maybe we'll take
play five check yep six will be a little
bit we can not particularly happy as
this position must be better for him
vporn it's just a weakness
okay if I did this and he takes bishop
age three this is quite annoying so I
don't think he can take we have met much
better trying to double them yeah I'm
going to push the second half pawn as
well now okay if I go F forehand group d
6 rupee 6v6 there are hoop takes c6
ideas because of the 95 discovery
[Music]
yes you will play it i think i need
counterclaim
booked a group tix group Jake's takes on
these three books is six I take one half
to this one okay okay so how to play we
should age three maybe at least if it
takes be 6a heck ever draw at least with
rook f1 f2 and maybe I have more and it
looks likely that i have more action but
not sure about it tough tough decision
for while but i also definitely
threatened to create him
whoopee 825 maybe not particularly
convincing
time wording I don't find a really good
solution here
would be six I expected
25 looks most likely yes and yeah I
don't don't have anything else I think
check
not clear how I do it ok check check
check check now camp it's very likely a
draw actually taken apart I didn't I
take the porn check check check check
check mate ok winning is a little bit a
little bit too much actually but I'm
happy that I'm somewhat offended this
position I failed ok at least yeah yeah
I mean in some cell i thought i'm in
some strategic trouble a couple of
months later ok so with the with the
beep beep on being weakish this is the
engine just take only five and maybe
I didn't really look at this I also
thinking I can hear them structures too
bad but you know this is not original
problem i keep it at f5 and that's the
true i can just take this ok but now i'm
definitely in some trouble but i felt
this was an ok player for you cannot
take because of picture of h 3's or that
one now this this is just probably just
not not good any other looks pretty bad
now when i played the second half poll
which may be off to visit him ya hear
the engine wants to take simply but 95
is also liked by the computer a queen
takes was mine what's the expected move
but oh look at five interesting and this
is a very drastic solution that I did
not see I here check I'm getting a draw
funny nope didn't see it came this one a
surety for so that was bad and we can
take and take on b6 Chen tough to play
this immediately is given by the combat
in this move yeah this is really i saw
that of course as an idea of it I didn't
quite see what to do after this move I
would you fire that is quite logical and
here we probably have a draw wild check
check now with the perpetual
[Music]
I Bishop takes you four was killing me I
was extremely lucky here while it just
ended ended the chat going to be a maid
and this is of course completely lost
okay so very very lucky okay okay and
attending should be a draw but somehow
he gave me gave me a pole for no
particular reason and then I refused to
take c4 which doesn't make any sense
maybe you wanted to check on g8 and
we'll the mouse club check now here you
stumbled and turn into this one I will
gauge forever King edge force is strong
with rolling yes tough game that I was
very lucky not to lose okay thanks for
watching